we have mike peterson who is the
director of bitcoin beach with us mike
let's bring you up here
mike how are you
doing excellent stoked to be with you
guys today on this monumental occasion
absolutely um let's start first with
help everyone understand your background
and kind of the origin story of bitcoin
beach for those that don't know
yeah so i wound up in el salvador about
17 years ago on a surf trip and fell in
love with the country and talked my wife
and buying a place here and about eight
years ago we moved to el salvador and
just saw a lot of the needs in our
community and around the country and so
we started investing in different
projects
and just kind of especially focusing on
algonte where we're at and two years ago
we kind of combined my love for bitcoin
with uh
the needs of the unbanked here and just
seeing how bitcoin could truly change
their lives even much more than it's
changed my life and so about two years
ago we started uh pushing bitcoin out
into the community through
um incentivizing kids to get good grades
um doing different work in the community
a lot of things really focused on
keeping them out of gangs gangs have
have historically been a big issue in el
salvador and so
um we never envisioned it taking off
into something that would change the
world's monetary system but it's been
yeah it's been a crazy ride
and when you think about those early
days of starting bitcoin beach um
what was the response did people look at
you like you were crazy did it strike
immediately people were like oh yeah
this makes sense let me start using it
like what was the reaction
both when you talked to the adults they
looked at you like you were crazy you
know people people my age you know
looked at it like this is insane like
what do you mean how do we touch a
bitcoin what do you mean no government
backs it
um you know they wanted to be able to
physically hold it and so it was really
a challenge for them but when we
switched to focusing on the youth for
them it was normal they're used to
living in a digital world they're used
to transacting digitally so for them it
made sense that money would be digital
and that it would be decentralized and
so
they were kind of the ones that taught
their parents
kind of like i have to have my kids help
me set up my iphone every time there's a
new uh version released they have helped
their their parents and grandparents
come along and start using bitcoin and
once they do it a few times they realize
especially using the lightning network
and some of the newer wallets that are
out there just how easy it is and so at
first it's daunting but quickly they get
over that yeah and today if you had to
describe uh kind of the pervasiveness of
this and the sentiment just in elizante
what exactly is the current state of
everything obviously jack mullers peter
mccormick a bunch of other bitcoiners
have gone down and
spent some time with you in the work
that you're doing but how would you
evaluate where you are right now
i'd say we're still definitely in the
early innings um we have the vast
majority of people in el zante have have
at least used bitcoin in some fashion
probably about half of them use bitcoin
you know pretty regularly you know
weekly
um a lot of them daily a lot of them are
earning their wages in bitcoin uh
definitely a lot of them are saving in
bitcoin and so i i
i'd say probably definitely more than
anywhere else in the world any other
community the the penetration of bitcoin
is probably 10 times you know the next
highest place
as it is here in el zante so it's been a
lot of fun just seeing the network
effects kick in and how real those are
when most people in the united states or
north america kind of the developed
world think of bitcoin usually they
actually think of it as an investment
asset something that they buy it goes up
in dollar value maybe they sell it maybe
they hold it but it's very much an
investment not so much a currency my
understanding of what's happening in el
zante is the exact opposite most people
don't look at it as an investment but
more so they look at it as a currency a
medium of exchange is that an accurate
portrayal or what is kind of the balance
between maybe an investment perspective
versus a currency as a like a medium of
exchange
i mean people definitely look at it as
both it's definitely a long-term savings
vehicle for a lot of them but it's
probably the inverse to that percentage
outside of alzheimer's you know most
people are like 80 focused on bitcoin as
digital gold and 20 focused on on the
you know using it as a transactional
money where in el zante i'd say it's the
reverse the 80 of the value comes from
the transactionalness of it and 20 from
the you know long term
number go up
and so i think a lot of people don't
realize
you know the vast majority of the world
doesn't have access to things like cash
app or venmo or those sorts of things so
for them even moving a small amount of
money can be a huge headache long bus
rides expensive and so anything from
trying to send twenty dollars to you
know your relative across the country to
you know for myself trying to buy a
vehicle here it's a major hurdle to get
money into the country and to move it
and bitcoin just kind of breaks down all
those barriers
when you think about the infrastructure
itself um when i first started here of
alzheimer's and bitcoin beach it seemed
like uh it was a little bit more onerous
the user experiences the infrastructure
wasn't quite there
now my take from what i hear from a
number of different people who have been
is this much more kind of lightning
network enabled there's uh micro
payments there's cheap kind of fast
transactions what are people using for
the most part is it the cash apps of the
world is it strike is it some other
piece of infrastructure and like what
does that user experience look like for
them
we've actually uh worked hand-in-hand
with uh with a small upstart lightning
company called galloway money and we've
developed the bitcoin beach wallet and
we've been able to kind of
integrate a lot of things that are
innovative like there's a map function
in there so you can actually click on
this map and see all the places that are
accepting bitcoin throughout el salvador
and then actually pay them from a
lightning payment directly through the
map they don't have to create an invoice
or anything like that we also use user
names and similar to how strike is doing
with the usernames and so i think
between strike and the bitcoin beach
wallet then you know those are the ones
that are primarily being used mostly
because they get rid of the friction i
mean it's just makes it very fast to do
a lightning transaction actually faster
than cash and so that was something we
had to come overcome initially some of
the store owners would say ah it takes
longer i have to create an invoice i
have to wait
where this it's actually faster and so i
think that's very important as far as
getting uptake on a real retail level
absolutely
obviously everyone is talking about el
salvador now and i think most people
know the origin
of bitcoin beach and the work that you
and your team has done there in el zante
but uh the president of el salvador uh
obviously pushed through the legislation
uh and they now have started to acquire
bitcoin what are people on the ground
thinking about this is this a positive
development is there concerns is there
kind of a
whole spectrum of reactions or emotions
like what are you hearing on the ground
no there's definitely a whole spectrum
one people have to realize it's become
very political because the president is
pushing it the opposition parties are
suddenly very anti-bitcoin uh i think if
he would have
tried to outlaw bitcoin they would be
protesting in favor of bitcoin so you
know you have to kind of throw out that
just the normal politics that happen in
any country
but on a real concern level there are
people here who just they don't
understand it they don't understand
what's happening they're being told that
they're going to be forced to use
bitcoin that it could drop you know the
value could go down in half overnight
and even today we've seen the value drop
down and that's very concerning for
people when they feel like they're going
to be forced to use it but that's not
the case the the way the law is written
nobody has to use bitcoin it's something
that i think the way they're trying to
do it is for over time people to
slowly increase their exposure as they
kind of
understand the volatility of it and so
yeah i think it's just kind of natural
for people to have those
those concerns when something new is
being pushed in yeah it makes complete
sense that i try to remind folks that uh
politics penetrate all kinds of things
like this here in the united states el
salvador and pretty much anywhere in the
world talk to me about the
chivo wallet and the atm uh plan that
the president has where they're kind of
i think they're putting 50 or 100 atms
around the country
what is the general perception that you
have right you've got a very unique seat
and then obviously you're a large
bitcoin proponent uh you've been very
active in helping on board a ton of
users in that country uh and also i
think um you know having the president
kind of do this you seem to be
supportive of that as well so how do you
see the rollout plan um in terms of
maybe the pros and cons in your opinion
i mean i think it'll be disastrous roll
out like any new technology roll out i
mean even the u.s government can't you
know roll out something with all the
resources they have behind them so you
know from from large governments to
large tech companies anytime something
new is rolled out it's very rocky at
first so i'm assuming it'll be the same
here maybe i'll be pleasantly surprised
but
i assume for most people they won't be
able to use the wallet this week and
then generally over time they'll they'll
kind of catch up with the volume they'll
work out the bugs and so i wouldn't be
surprised if you know two weeks from now
people are calling this a failure
but
three months from now everybody
realizing wow this actually works and
it's revolutionizing the way commerce is
happening in el salvador it's saving
people money and it's giving people
access to the hardest money on earth
that people are able to save and
something that's not depreciating over
time so
i really have a long view of this it's
not a short game this is definitely a
long game and i think the president here
knows that and so i think he will stick
to it you know for the long term even
through the bumps and yeah so i would
just tell people to hold their judgment
until
we get at least six months out
that uh i think that's a very fair point
uh when you look forward uh one of the
things i'm personally interested in is
can el salvador essentially embrace
bitcoin and potentially move from a
developing nation to a developed nation
can it launch itself forward and kind of
move up in uh the world order if you
will um how do you see bitcoin impacting
the country uh economically and socially
uh over the next you know 20 25 years is
something that you're you're ultra
bullish on or how do you view this
no super bullish i mean people
people overestimate what can happen in a
year but they underestimate what can
happen in 10 years and so i think the
changes are going to be slow there's
going to be jobs i mean we're already
seeing dozens of companies coming in
opening up legal entities hiring people
that are paying significantly above the
local wages and so you're going to have
this influx not just of better paying
jobs but opportunity for people to
increase their skills and that's also
going to drive the
people into furthering their education
because that's been a big challenge here
people like well why would i go to
university if there's not going to be a
job waiting for me at the end and so i
think
10 years from now it'll be shocking the
difference that we see in el salvador
that the majority of the people will be
going to university that the majority of
the people will um not be working in
cornfields but they'll be working in the
tech sector they'll be working in the
finance sector
and el salvador will really be like a
regional hub and leader you know similar
to like a singapore
yeah and when you start to think about
how important maybe let's start with the
country's youth is right um it seems to
me that the bitcoin as an asset could be
hyper bullish for a country but you need
the people to participate as well what
has your experience been with the young
people you described a little bit
earlier that they immediately got
currency that wasn't backed by a country
and they seemed much more receptive to
it is it something where you see them
just using it are they excited about it
as a savings technology are they out
kind of educating their friends and and
talking to people like what do they seem
to be doing because to me they are the
future of the country right
no they definitely are excited about it
i mean of course like anybody their
emotions kind of go up and down with the
price fluctuations and so you know when
we were looking back in january february
everybody was ultra bullish and you know
super excited uh you know then we went
into kind of the downturn and and people
were a little more hesitant about things
actually we hardly saw anybody sell most
of them held through that um and so that
was kind of really encouraging to see
but yeah they are excited not just about
the the fact that it can go up in value
but the fact that it connects them to
the broader world for the first time
they feel like proud to be here in el
salvador that they're not 10 years
behind the rest of the world they're
actually 10 years ahead of the rest of
the world
and so they are leading this
and i don't think you can underestimate
the impact that that has on people just
that hope and that motivation that there
is a future here and they can be part of
it
yeah one of the pieces um that i think
folks need to be careful of is obviously
salvadorians
have great pride in their country
and i think that they're very interested
from the folks that i've talked with in
building a better future
for their country but obviously
bitcoiners from around the world both in
america and elsewhere
seem to be attracted to the country now
some of that is through the economic
incentives some of that is just wanting
to be around and surrounded by uh
like-minded individuals and so there's a
lot of tourists or international
travelers that keep going there any
thoughts on um how helpful those people
from outside the country can be are
there risks to too many you know kind of
non-salvadorians coming is there
resentment at all or maybe there's
positive reception like how do you just
think about the local citizens versus
those that are coming there because of
bitcoin
i think it's definitely mixed i mean
we've seen a lot of people here come
here for self-serving purposes they're
just trying to ride the
wave of publicity about el salvador and
tie themselves to it and you know a lot
of them with projects that i would view
as scams and so you know we're
definitely concerned about that but in
general i've been very impressed of the
number of you know large companies that
have come in here and have expressed
this view of you know el salvador is a
small country we don't assume you know
we don't expect to make money here but
we just really want to support what's
going on and be part of it in some way
and so we're willing to invest even if
it doesn't pay dividends here we feel
like as far as for the overall
um infrastructure of bitcoin and for the
future of bitcoin that is super
important and so yeah we definitely
encourage people to come to el salvador
but not with a a view that you're going
to teach the people here something with
the view that you're going to learn from
them like how are people really using
bitcoin in real transactional ways these
people here that are living in a tin
shack with a dirt floor are doing you
know hundreds of bitcoin transactions a
year which is you know dwarfs what even
some of the biggest bitcoiners in the us
are doing so they really understand the
logistical problems they understand the
infrastructure problems with with
internet connectivity and those sorts of
things
and they can really
teach the bitcoin companies how to build
products that can go out to bigger
developing countries like india or or
all throughout africa and so i think
they can really use um el salvador as as
a learning center for what will work and
that will also benefit el salvador
because it just brings in all these
high-paying jobs and and provides um
a environment where locals can start
bitcoin businesses that can thrive
what is your message or kind of guidance
for those that can't travel to el
salvador so plenty of people kind of
internationally are very interested
they're watching this is there anything
they can do to help or kind of further
uh the development of this
yeah so we we often will post things
with projects that we're trying to raise
funds to support you know the education
of locals for them to go to university
or things like that we have a number of
projects for the bitcoin beach project
that that we're always open to people
helping financially support um but i
think also just to kind of keep
following it and to have an open mind
and to not jump to conclusions if we
have like a bad month or we hit a
roadblock you know this is going to be a
long term game and so i think we need to
be in this for the long haul
my brothers are here with me i think
they've got a couple of questions as
well what questions you guys got hey
mike thanks for doing this uh big fan of
kind of what you guys are doing down
there on the ground in el salvador my
question would be around kind of the
volatility of bitcoin and what you've
seen with the citizens using it there so
i i think as a savings uh technology and
kind of a savings platform for people to
invest their money and save it it makes
a lot of sense from a volatility
perspective i think a lot of the
pushback has always been that uh from my
understanding right if you go buy a
coffee in el salvador it's a us dollar
price and then you give them a bitcoin
as an exchange
have citizens complained or have you got
any feedback or pushback on kind of the
volatility of bitcoin or is it something
where they're seeing it appreciate over
time so it's a little more comfortable
or is there that day-to-day swing that
makes them a little uneasy
i mean i would say all i mean it's it's
there's no denying that the volatility
is a challenge for bitcoin the fact that
you know the volatility has historically
been going up i think is helpful so
people have that kind of long view that
maybe you know they lose money you know
in dollar terms this month but you know
overall they're going to be in a better
situation um but i think that's just
part of the process of bitcoin
monetizing that it's trying to find its
value and so you know i think we still
have several years of this which is why
i think it's the gu it was very wise of
the government to put into the wallet
the ability for people to auto convert
uh there's the ability for them to hold
their value in dollars but still utilize
the bitcoin payment rails and i think
that's an important distinction that a
lot of people don't understand
especially the mainstream press they
don't understand the difference between
you know bitcoin the asset and bitcoin
the payment rails and so it's the
bitcoin payment rails that are really
the most important for the country at
this juncture
and that can be the
volatility can be mitigated by holding
in dollars and allowing
in that auto convert function
gotcha
john what questions you got yeah mike
thank you for doing this um really big
fan of what you guys are doing as joe
said but um i'm curious more about the
the customers and the businesses how are
they interacting um and then like is it
kind of being adopted seamlessly by the
customers in the businesses and then
what tools are the businesses
specifically using
to accept bitcoin as a payment to do any
loyalty programs that they have like
what is it like from their perspective
so most uh the businesses that we've
been working with here and also are very
small mom-and-pop businesses so they're
businesses that never would be qualified
to accept credit cards and so for them
this is the first time for them to have
any type of mobile payments um network
and they're just fascinated by the fact
that now you know somebody can send
bitcoin from across town without having
to be physically present and they can
send a little delivery boy to you know
go deliver them their papoosas or their
groceries and so for them it's been a
huge asset to kind of have this whole
digital world opened up to them for the
first time
most of them have been using the bitcoin
beach wallet developed by galloway money
and that's because the team from galway
spent several months here and have kind
of learned how the people used it they
saw the things that didn't make sense to
them there's oftentimes a big disconnect
from the developers who kind of live in
their own bubble versus you know
specifically people in a developing
country and so i think it's very
important that we build wallets and
tools that are actually what the users
want not what the developers want
perfectly said
mike i got two more questions for you
and then we'll uh we'll let you go is
one when you think about uh
bitcoin and the continued move forward
uh the president is tweeting and he
tweeted yesterday that they bought 200
bitcoin he then tweeted they bought
another 200. uh and then today during
the dip he essentially tweeted uh that
they bought the dip bought 150 bitcoin
said thanks imf uh you know kind of in
some way was using twitter um in a very
different way than most heads of state
use
how do you evaluate uh bitcoin the use
of twitter and the el salvadorian um or
the salvadorian like economy and and the
people are they excited by this do they
not like it like it just seems like it's
so different that you could almost make
an argument that it's good or bad we
were discussing earlier on the show is
you know it could be a positive for
bitcoin it could be a negative it could
be a positive for el salvador it could
be a negative same for the president how
do you view it in terms of almost like
the real time uh information sharing and
the transparency and the engagement that
maybe other heads of state uh don't
participate in
yeah i think for bitcoin there's no
question it'll it'll be beneficial i
mean even even if things go sour or
something unexpected happens and you
know there's a really negative impact
just the fact that people are exposed to
bitcoin for their first time and you
know that sticks with them and so i
think regardless of what happens here on
the government level el salvador will be
a major hub for bitcoin just because
once people are exposed to bitcoin they
they rarely let it go
as far as for el salvador i think
there's huge opportunities um we've
already seen it just the amount of
earned media that they've gotten from
from this decision i mean it's worth
tens of billions of dollars just all the
focus that's been on el salvador and
mostly in a positive light you know
looking at them being forward thinking
and embracing new technology versus
historically they've only the news is
only focused on el salvador when there
was a you know big gang shootings or
things like that and so it's really
flipped the script on people's
perception of el salvador and i don't
think you can underestimate the value of
that and then also the number of
companies that are locating here that
like literally could not have pointed
out bitcoin on a map six months ago and
now are opening offices here
and not just paying better but they're
providing that opportunity for people to
increase their education and the people
that are working for these companies now
will have the skills to go out and start
their own companies and so
i i think regardless
of what happens and regardless of the
ups and downs el salvador is going to be
the most prosperous country in central
america maybe latin america you know 10
years from now and i think bitcoin is
going to increase because definitely el
salvador is not going to be the last
country to embrace it i'm hearing all
kinds of rumors of other countries that
are looking to go the same direction and
so i think it's just a matter of time
till that happens i'm sure right now
they're sitting back a little bit to see
how this works out and if it works out
well they'll jump in if if there's some
you know big stumbles along the way
they'll probably wait but you know that
might just be the difference between it
being six months before the next you
know announcement in 16 months so i
think it's inevitable that that's the
way the world's going to go
yeah i tend to agree with you obviously
uh more so than not uh last question i
have for you which is a fun one uh
bitcoin is in uh what appears to be a
bull run any price predictions or
thoughts as to where bitcoin's price
goes through the rest of this year
i mean i i personally don't think we're
done with the cycles um i i like the
super cycle idea i would love to think
that we you know are going to have
decreased volatility but
i you know i'm hesitant to make price
predictions because
everybody knows how uh you know that's
worse than trying to predict the weather
but i would guess somewhere in the 150
range you know into the end of the year
but i still think we'll have a big
pullback in the next year i hope i'm
wrong but that's kind of what i'm
assuming but i do know 10 years from now
it'll be you know at least 10x what it
is now and so that's more what i'm
focused on so you think 10 years 500 000
or more is pretty safe bet
yeah i mean easy i
i would make that bet all day long
so so would i my friend i am making that
bet as i assume you are as well
[Laughter]
um all right uh we've got your twitter
account here um where uh we've been
telling people to go follow you and
engage uh at bitcoin beach is there
anywhere else that you want us to send
folks um to uh to find more about the
work you're doing or check out anything
that you guys have built
yeah so we also have a website it's just
wwe
but we are we are more current on
twitter the the website is kind of more
of a static page but it's a good place
for people to go to to kind of see
pictures of the team there and that sort
of thing
all right and then actually i lied i
have one more question how good is the
surfing down there
the surfing in el salvador is horrible
don't come here
it's absolutely horrible bitcoin sucks
and surfing in el salvador sucks perfect
great message
the surfing is amazing it really is it's
i'm a little hesitant to tell people
that because i'm getting older so it's
harder for me to fight for waves so i
don't want the crowds to descend too
fast but uh but yeah it's an amazing
it's an amazing town it's amazing
country and lots of good waves and warm
water and especially warm people
that's awesome man well listen thank you
so much for taking the time out of uh
out of this kind of historic day and uh
you know just thank you from me and my
brothers and everyone else in the
bitcoin community have been doing some
amazing work down there um and i think
the results speak for themselves so keep
up the great work and we'll have to talk
again in the future as you guys continue
progressing
well hopefully next time we talk you're
here in el zante so uh just let us know
when you're ready to come down i i i i
don't know if you know this but i almost
made a trip uh with uh the second best
bitcoin podcaster in the world peter
mccormick but uh we couldn't make the uh
the dates work so i'm gonna come down
there uh but hopefully i come when he's
not there so everyone thinks that i'm
cool because he's not there to uh to
outshine me right
well he must have got hung up on
something because he told me he was
gonna come barge in and uh you know
crash our podcast today so he he's
probably off interviewing the president
or something right now
no no don't give him any credit he's
probably he's probably down the street
uh either uh
surfing drinking or on twitter trying to
figure out how he can get my attention
by tweeting at me incessantly stupid
things
[Laughter]
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this we'll definitely do it again
all right sounds good we'll see you guys
bye
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]